obviously you love going to to
basketball games you love the NBA you
get into fights a lot with players
during the game you are now some
celebrities do that occasionally you
seem to do it like you make a point
every every time every time any time
what's going on I go to argue with the
players I mean I'm friends with a lot of
them
you know because I'm a I'm a popular guy
so you can tell that from the intro what
came out I'm not sure what happened if I
went with you to a basketball game no
one would watch the game or or we or we
probably wouldn't get seats every one of
the other so what I do is I go there and
because you're courtside you know it
gives you the ability to go back and
forth with the players and I like to do
it at a very high level you know I take
I take my level of annoyance is it as
high as it can possibly go and I just do
it it today today today give it like you
know I've told guys that that their legs
were fake I've told the bride James one
time that I thought you had butt shots
during the game but it's not real people
were getting ahead yuh-huh James Harden
once during a game tough you yeah he
kicked you yeah they got me good too
right in the shin right in the shin now
did anyone intervene did officials that
you don't like to kick no the ref saw it
and let it happen the ref actually was
on James inside see it here's what
happened but they were in Philadelphia
the Houston Rockets are playing the
Sixers I'm a Sixers fan okay so I'm
giving it to James I'm talking the best
trash that I've ever talked in my life I
told him that people live in his beard
really really giving it to him they said
Kevin shut up he said I'm gonna turn it
up and I'm gonna really give you a city
to business and I was like what you say
in what you do is two different things
brother you need to look at the
scoreboard and at the point like he had
like ten points at the time James Harden
went on a score of 52 points oh my god
and at the end of it when the game was
over he came over he's like see what you
did to your city and he said kick him
right in the shin and it was one of
those moments where you immediately look
for help and I know rats are nothing the
ref was like the ref gave me a look to
say you got what you deserved
yeah yeah it was one of those moments
you